hey everyone Deadpool 2 released a new
trailer this week it featured a Deadpool
forming the x-force a team of
militaristic mutant mercenaries in the
Marvel Comics I had a joke about there
being a lot of em's but I don't want to
do it in air because it feels wrong
because I screwed up there was a
previous take of this whatever there's a
story behind this team we're gonna get
to it what changes has a movie made from
the comics and how will they change the
dynamic of a superhero team-up movies in
general well we'll see we'll talk about
that but for now let's welcome all of
you to new rockstars news it's gonna
also talk about more Deadpool news but
also major updates from the Warner
Brothers DC movies more stuff you guys
need to know about I'm Erik Voss joining
me at the table are hi i'm mod garrett
over here is Sam Bash and I wish I did
that entrance even slower yeah we got
all the time in the world right like you
guys are in for the long haul we're the
new a weird being off force right an
armed force it's not derivative because
that's my superpowers just explaining
things that people already well yeah
let's start with our top story the new
trailer for Deadpool 2 now perhaps the
biggest takeaway from this trailer it
was the confirmation that the x-force
will definitely play a Roma story it's
not gonna be any backdoor post-credits
scene tease of a future x-force team up
guys they're already here Wow oh man now
the trailer already shows Deadpool
planning important to protect the young
mutant played by Julian Dennison from
the clutches of cable in order to do
that he assembles the x-force the team
as we see it now consists of Domino
that's Easybeats character she's a
mercenary with incredible marksmanship
hand hand combat and she can alter the
probability of scenarios at least in the
comics we'll see what that means yeah
cool she kind of just like uses psychic
telekinetic stuff yes lucky yeah
now there was also a shot of Terry Crews
in
you go watch my trailer breakdown you'll
see that miscible clue that tells us
that he's actually playing bedlam bedlam
can create this like bio electromagnetic
field that can sense and disrupt other
mutants power that's helpful or useful
especially when you're working with
someone like cable also my Charley
breakdown and pointed out how you can
barely make out bill skarsgård who's
penny wise in it and Rob Delaney Twitter
comedian uh as other members of the team
now I speculated that they could be
playing characters in scars guards case
maybe chamber or zeitgeist and then for
Delaney's case maybe pete wisdom his
head shots at Peter or the character
shatter star cuz it's kind of he's a
member of the x-force and you can that's
kind of what he looks like with that
helmet now in the comics this team
wasn't actually created by Deadpool it
was led by cable as you know this
militaristic blackops version could be
the x-men could be yeah they might be
doing some kind of like altered
backstory ha the 90s the 90s time right
how many muscles is sort of now this
classic lineup here play that like a hub
everyone screaming so many pouches this
is a cable and boomer boom boom also
known as cannonball copycat sometimes
Domino they kind of interchange ferrule
shatter star Richter warpath sunspot
there was kind of a rotating cast now
these guys were a bunch of over-the-top
aggro they went on crazy
extreme violent missions with some nods
to cables mysterious backstory
eventually just spun off into its own
storylines
over the years the x-force has been
relaunched a whole bunch of times with
rotating lineups actually in a more
recent run Deadpool actually joins a
team but the x-force really peaked in
popularity in the early 90s when both
Marvel and DC comics are really just
kind of going through an identity crisis
of their own and artists like Rob
Liefeld
this guy did it to depict everyone with
these like hulking impractical screaming
perform couches more particular sort of
accessories more Jem and the Holograms
meets real hard drives yeah yeah like
everyone everyone screaming no one has
feet that look real they're just like
little elf triangle probably
never looks ridiculous quads with more
bandoliers around a five for whatever
reason yeah it was an insane period of
comics it's you know that's kind of
what's fun about x-force in cable
honestly right like they're crazy
they're ridiculous they don't make sense
and they're kind of perfect for the for
the Deadpool movies because you know he
could just like mock and make fun of
them and point out how ridiculous is all
is it looks like this movie made some
exciting casting choices for this freak
show you have Josh Brolin Terry Crews
desi beets Bill skarsgård Rob Delaney
and of course let's not forget the other
mutant characters that are coming back
for this movie negasonic teenage warhead
colossus and the new characters like
Cherie could soonas new character she's
the one with the electronic whip stuff
and we're thinking she might be surge
and then julia Denison's new character
of course now some people say with his
fire abilities he could be pyro or
sunspot there's a theory I get into in
the breakdown that he might be Genesis
Weaver sunspot that's pot yeah so in two
different things he's in Days of Future
past and he's gonna be in immune so yeah
so we'll see might be playing Evan the
the clone of jente of apocalypse is one
period I saw that was very I wish is
just Ricky Baker from the welder people
I wish can I do it Ricky Baker's great
honeymoon yeah yeah something we're
saying made that like the Wolverine oh
well I is excited obviously Avengers
infinity war is going to dominate the
start of the summer movie season in
April oh yeah
dip will too it looks like it's such a
fun be cast of mutants so what do you
guys see x-force bringing to the
superhero movies that has been missing
so let's talk about some of the facts
that have already happened or not
is that they did an audience screening
or I think was internal for feedback and
they loved Domino's so much that they
went back and did Ridge reshoots and
added more dialogue and more of her good
sounds really great to me I love that we
have a strong female character cuz like
I don't know the first Deadpool my
favorite was um Ted Paul's girlfriend I
thought she was the best character and
it's like the other ones had room to
grow but it was kind of all over because
it was the Deadpool show so hearing that
I think's fantastic and like Brolin he's
what is he the busiest man four
consecutive movies coming out I think
from April where Deadpool - Avengers or
two other two more that sounds like you
know people that like movies will we'll
go see it took a war movie and it's not
something someone else all I think of is
you know they see me rollin well for I'm
excited - they leaned into like the
comedy for wall that's what's called
breaking tendencies of Deadpool -
couldn't think of it for a second but I
think they should need to lean into this
as much as possible like a Terry Crews
are already like Terry Crews yeah I want
I'd want like exact exaggerate it more
and you're like what am i weird fetish
like is this a fantasy that we're
looking at maybe but it's still like if
you haven't beating up people and having
funny jokes you're good like you're
having a good time but like leaning into
the different aspects of comic books in
a way that you can they can make fun of
it so that's always that's what made it
pull so much funnier one aspect of it
that made it so much fun yeah this could
be an unpopular opinion but usually
team-ups within the x-men world aren't
so much fun you know like wow I mean I
love her
Nightcrawler came in and was like boom
and I provided that different thing you
know all right this is all right but
then we went younger and I was like in
like first class is great young Cyclops
and like that yeah back yeah yeah don't
do that
go away so I and I think it just missed
fun it just means like you know they
took the characters a little bit
seriously Oscar Isaac it's my least
favorite role I've ever seen him dude
needed if you know an injection of
extreme BS fun camp awesomeness r-rating
yeah I think this is the period of
comics that like the movie adaptations
have tended to kind of ignore and look
over cuz it's kind of depending on your
thoughts or a bit of a Dark Ages in
comics you know like all DC and Marvel
were still kind of figuring out what to
do with themselves they you know we're
kind of losing a lot of money
they killed Superman they had Bane break
Batman's back the x-men and all the
Marvel Universe was kind of like finding
its way and they they were doing a lot
of like experimentation reinvention this
is just kind of a crazy period and you
know I was I was talking with a Devon or
awesome editor and producer he we were
saying how like in when I was you know
growing up in the early 90s it took me a
while to get into comics since because I
would just like walk through and see on
the shelves this kind of stuff and I'm
like I don't recognize a lot of these
guys the people who I would see in like
you know the x-men animated series in
the Batman animated series a Batman take
me a while to go like find the comics
that I wanted and I kind of had like a
delayed start to get into comics because
of this and I want to see like a movie
try to tackle how crazy this is because
I think you need to be an adult to
appreciate it's not super super kid
friendly and so having an r-rating on
that's gonna be great yeah it's gonna be
fun this is I like to call these the why
not comics why not yeah and make him
enormous bullets why would you carry
them that way right
yeah men I know they're all individually
loose bullets in each pouch like load
each one into the clip it's really so
hard to explain all these characters to
like people who aren't familiar with the
comics because it's like well yeah cable
he has like he has a techno-organic eye
that can see in infrared spectrum but he
also has like a Anna techno-organic arm
he does take no heed virus that was but
he also like travels through time so
he's like Scott Summers is a kid with a
clone of Jean Grey things went so insane
they couldn't just like have one thing
they had so many crazy so many hats on a
hat so many pouches on pouches
so it's it's just this period of comics
that are just like insane and if you
could like you know Deadpool just kind
of embraces me he's already kind of a
crazy character and I think that what
made that pulling cables such a fun
team-up series in the comics I've at the
pouch yeah also I'm when you saw him
riding around the professor Eck's
these trailers like when as soon as it
dropped I was like all right I need to
be comfortable and I want to just I want
mr. wash over me like I'm so excited for
these trailers because they just deliver
I'm glad he gets to walk around the xmin
mansion - yeah before he was outside of
it yeah this is like I hopefully will
see how well this does i Andrew Goddard
is doing the x-force team up movie he's
starting to shoot it in October last
week heard so come out at some point in
2019 I'm really excited to see like this
side of the superhero movie adaptation
as much as I love the Avengers and and
all those team-ups at this point they
kind of have to be a little self-serious
kind like a day of reckoning for all the
Avengers and they've already had all
their fun so now it's time to grow up a
little bit but for now I'm excited to
see at least until you know the DC or
not DC Oh
Disney and Vox merges all these things
into one massive cinematic universe
excited to see like their own kind of
style this r-rated you know and embrace
that ultraviolence in this insane way
it's just the cheek that I love this is
a cheeky Miss cheeky she's got a cheek
bear and it there and it there's some
head if he said on you you'd die yeah I
think he would die too just like he
would break the dimensional views
because he's got like you can see all
sides of his head on the same time yeah
it's fascinating okay well yeah let us
know what you're most excited about with
with x-force and and how you hope it
might change or restore certain things
about comic movie adaptations and the
way that you your inner fanboy would
want but for now let's move on to this
week's trivia question it's my favorite
that's really the best part of this
right it's why are you all tuned in
right
some people get it right in the comments
and I am in so impressed it's almost
like they had a search engine at their
disposal that they could now they
wouldn't dare they would yeah we yeah
you guys are honesty ok well this week's
trivia question it's gonna stay in the
Deadpool world here in the first
Deadpool movie which celebrity cameo was
cut from the movie it was the movie's
original closing scene for being too
insensitive interesting ok so it's gonna
require you to like just know things so
hopefully you'll watch the commentary on
what I did I do not remember later this
show will reveal the answer to this
trivia question close answer has decided
by our judges will get to do our
scientific advice at the end of the
video whereas the loser will have to
cleverly riff on all of our in other
news headlines you know they have and
I'll give you $20 you know we all don't
know this is just firing blanks come on
man I couldn't be the vs. do it hey I
can't be the furthest away Sam losing
trivia on new rock stars for Halloween
and people go what's happening on but
she okay she called duster know you've
been ball seen on the ground making up
words that I didn't know those vowel
sounds it was old so right I mean I was
there like I wake up in the morning okay
a quick news flash update here guys Ava
Duvernay or duverney director of a
wrinkle and time and a number of
acclaimed films will direct a New Gods
movie for Warner Brothers and the DCE
yuh-huh now just uh some info here the
New Gods are from the DC Comics a future
heroes from the planets of New Genesis
and apocalypse apocalypse remembers a
home were homeworld of a Darkseid
Duvernay has tweet in the past that her
favorite superhero all-time as big Barda
who's from the the New Gods saying that
this part of everybody she's great but
out of a pin anyways continues it was
yeah something big big but I got nothing
making those big bucks
from being here no one got it I said big
bada-boom
oh yeah not to get it move on no I've
done even know
so anyway apparently the the audience is
pretty split about this news because
wrinkle in time to a lot of people not
so great okay oh why she turned into
this territory now but stop being so
protective always getting made is what I
see well it's also like a big epic
they're like it's like teaching a whole
religion to somebody and then making an
epic out of that it's a big it's a big
it's a big thing and wrinkle in time was
big and I didn't do amazing that was a
really hot book to translate so I was
new good news is like crazy definitely
written on acid type of storytelling but
yeah or she even got this assignment if
she was like saying that big barters her
favorite case she seems like someone
who's like a true fan as a prize you
know that she was a publicist for a long
time and the first time she picked up a
camera was 32 whoa boom and that's why
she's so good to interview because she
gets it soundbite see ok everyone it has
been a big week in news for the DCE you
over at Warner Brothers so to keep you
all from having to go back here and look
around across several different web
sites for all this info we thought we'd
break down all the updates that you need
to know cool you with us awesome ok
first the biggest news is that the
upcoming Batman solo film directed by
matt reeves which still technically has
ben affleck attached even though he'll
probably be replaced jake gyllenhaal
will see will not go into production
until 2019 we probably won't even see
any film in theaters until 2020 at the
earliest
meanwhile the Warner Brothers Studio has
three DC movies that are being shot in
2018 hmm Shazam the Wonder Woman's
sequel remember that as Kristen Wiig
recently cast as a fill-in cheetah and
then the Todd Phillips joke her origin
movie which sounds like it will feature
the Joker as they failed eighties
comedian as we heard about
for that the recognition is it's amazing
okay and we mentioned Shazam stars asher
angel he's playing Billy Batson and
Zachary Levi claimed Sam
took a break from shooting to do a
Facebook livestream this week where Levi
described the movie as Superman meets
big which have you know the characters
it is a good description of how that was
geared for kids you think uh I think so
that's what they were trying to say this
is a family-friendly fun light-hearted
costume hey it's great he looks like an
action figure they blew up if he doesn't
talk like this when his Shazam I'll be
really upset well he's also got a brain
of a kid so it's like he's gonna try to
like emulate like Superman Superman
talks like that so I'll try I'm excited
for the movie man can't every once just
as long as he's got a real lip while the
actresses movies are very excited about
it too I mean they they're like this
safety see you you know so she's like
trying to take away the missed out for
just sitting there crying it doesn't
look good done yeah dad it doesn't look
good I don't know what to do with it
mine's a quitter you ship over those
dailies so we can get this movie in
theaters middle with your internet tubes
and fix it nerd in a dark dark editing
Bay just does you here you open the room
we don't know what to do the way we have
sound a week I made it like 10 years
time it's like wow you see what happens
that guy's top lip they snap recently an
SNL skit about the coffee show thing
sorry we digress we digress okay well
guys the closest big event on the DC
calendars of course Aquaman we should be
in a trailer board very soon perhaps by
the time actually you're watching this
video there's already a trailer port and
then future me is busy working on it in
my dark room and it's like I'm losing my
mind but keep an eye out for that
trailer test audiences apparently
according to rumors I've been coming out
of smoothies loving it I don't know it's
just like you know insiders at the
studios spinning that good really good
things
yeah I'm James Wan is my hero so yeah
he's watched conjuring 2 and that is
saying a lot if you watch the first one
are just a drink - ah first conjuring is
good and they're all making a lot of
money b8 yeah um well you know maybe
DC's is realizing that their solo movies
like Wonder Woman tend to be easier to
pull off than these big team of events
like Justice League and Suicide Squad
surprisingly we actually learned this
week that Justice League has been a
lowest-grossing DCE movie so far made
229 million domestically which is you
know nice to make they probably a lot
more than that but it made a lot more
internationally it made close to a
billion internationally but still that's
less than Man of Steel Suicide Squad at
Batman vs Superman of course one woman's
the most profitable of those five even
though I thought quality-wise Justice
League was better than Man of Steel and
Sousa those three movies I think so in
terms of like character development
characters be most confident in terms of
who they are I mean it had Wonder Woman
in it and she's always great
I think the relationship like the
motivation behind Bruce Wayne actually
made sense as opposed to Batman vs
Superman we are agreeing that Justice
League is better than Batman V Superman
yeah yeah grateful I had I mean the only
debate there I would say maybe you might
think Man of Steel is a better movie I
just couldn't get past Manistee on how
like callous like the collateral damage
wasn't the third act and what they did
with him with Zod it just that to me I'm
like you fundamentally did not
understand the character but I think he
they fixed a lot of mistakes with
Justice League I don't know I'm a
defender of it now analysts are pointing
to the damage that movies like Batman
Superman and Suicide Squad might have
done to the franchise brand you know may
have it led some fans to prematurely
writing off Justice League on
fairly and then that combined with just
leaves well-documented production woes
which I think just affected too many
liked reviewers minds in terms of how
they were describing what this movie was
in terms of what the story was behind
the scenes which it's not important to
audiences alright shouldn't be important
but again it's not all doom and gloom
you know Wonder Woman has the
highest-grossing DCU movie box office
total she's getting a sequel and Warner
seems to be moving more towards like
solo films like that was with with
Shazam and an Aquaman and flash point
you know what's most excited about what
the future of DC flash not a flashpoint
and that's all they should do it like
Keys should be like spider-man he should
be great he should be grounded he should
be like like he's like he's with the
people he hangs out with the people like
spider-man's part of Queens like that's
how you know it like he flashed apart
central city he fights bank robbers he's
not when you show him do flashpoint
flash wants a really selfish storyline
he tries to save his mom but he nukes
the whole world spoilers that's
basically what happens and then he tries
to fix it but he makes everything well
not bad like it safe he just makes it
not the apocalypse which doesn't exactly
so it's like you could just show him
being a like street-level hero and being
okay like that's fine that would
actually really complement his role in
Justice League where he's learning
everything for the first time you know
and he can count on like spider-man
count on someone like Ironman as a
mentor and you know I think that that's
how you could utilize Ben Affleck really
really well as a flash mentor or someone
like that but as far as yeah I think
that's ambitious oh well too ambitious
Shazam is a fun one have fun just have
fun with the movie make it a comedy just
don't make it cringe-worthy Shazam's a
fun idea it's a kid who gives me a
superhero have fun with that idea it's
like you can get like elements of Iron
Giant in there a little bit then he gets
to hang out with like this bigger
character and for Billy its Billy gets
to choose to like the the character
they're gonna pick for this is basically
a kid who's hurt a lot but he gets he
has a choice to actually be better and
also he gets to share that power with
all of his foster siblings too and so
they all get to be other versions of
Shazam as well which is cool also there
might be attacking a talking tiger I
don't know how they're going to do that
that'd be really cool have you know seen
Jungle Book I mean no I just don't know
how I'll make any sense but it could
happen yeah in the Facebook live video
there at like some kind of carnival
booth and they were a bunch of stuffed
Tigers behind them they might been a
little wink too
yeah I'm really excited for it it hasn't
really been talked about cuz it's still
just kind of like being developed right
now that doesn't even have a writer or
director attaches the Green Lantern
Corps movie like III that what I saw
that announced by Warner Brothers I'm
like that could be a really fun like
procedural type movie and like just an
entire organization of Green Lantern's
that could like if they're willing to go
there that could be another guardians of
the galaxy type movie for sure that
would be really fun I just want a Batman
in death direct showdown
yes I'm a simple girl with simple needs
and that's what I want to say and like
we saw Joe Manganiello as Deathstroke
right the way I I kind of want that to
be DC's Cable in a way you know well
like you know the serious Deadpool which
is but I really think that you know and
I'm gonna compare Joe and Zach because
they're both huge geeks like they are
actual hardcore nerds and I really do
think that having a character in the
space that is a real nerd like they wear
it so much more and it's such an honor
and they get it and they understand it
and I think that that's so important
which is why I do have faith in Shazam
it's why so much so I want to see
Deathstroke also maybe we're talking
about the rated director being attached
to it and that you've ever just want to
see action like really good Deathstroke
action like give watch a little bit of
rate or rate - that would be amazing
it'd be next level it would be one of
the best movies of the summer if it came
out they might not let us know what you
are most looking forward to with these
DC movies a Wonder Woman Aquaman The
Joker origin movie we've done other
videos about that hopefully a Batman
movie that'll come out in a couple years
did we do fan casting for a new Joker
I think we did talk about that right we
was walking Phoenix is one being rumored
mmm I mean he's up for everything he's
up for everything they're always like a
walking fix made for Doctor Strange if
like Iron Man or something it's like
he's not gonna or Hulk he was up for
that for a second it was like Hulk Hogan
yes yes he was gonna be an Avenger
you better laugh at my jokes brother
everyone did I sat on it big dump on it
okay well guys hey comment down below
remember to subscribe to new rock stars
for all of our DC coverage thanks guys
yeah thanks another quick update about
big news from this week Tessa Thompson
of course who played Valkyrie in Thor
Ragnarok will join Chris Hemsworth also
from Thor Ragnarok in the upcoming Men
in Black reboot they're keeping these
two together they're shipping them they
had great chemistry right and now
they're gonna be in a minute black
together they're both so funny it's
gonna be great they are funny I think
that gets overshadowed a lot of the time
like Chris in Ghostbusters was actually
really really quite entertaining and I
really like this dynamic and I think I
mean it blacks you know they milked it
when it was really great back in the day
and I've left enough time to look at
again know and maybe they'll get Thanos
back in it right cuz Josh Brolin's an
everyday okay alright well let's move on
actually move back to Deadpool right
okay the other big Deadpool two news
this week was that there were reshoots
through the movie and we've previously
reported that test screenings weren't
great but and they had all these
reshoots to fix and put came home Domino
in the movie but it wasn't that case
that was that was that was pretty mature
to say that the test screens were going
great and the reshoots were only
scheduled for six days which is actually
really low for a big action franchise
movie yeah star wars most the time they
have to do weeks and weeks of reshoots
especially when a new director comes in
now according to the reports those
reshoots included a secret cameo by a
new character hush-hush some have
speculated could be Patrick Stewart or
James McAvoy as Charles Xavier you know
it depends on where in the timeline this
is I guess we saw his wheelchair in the
trailer Charles Xavier whose wheelchair
now there's I think it might be Hugh
Jackman as Wolverine remember now that
Disney owns all the Fox's properties
that could open up the world of cameos
from any number of superheroes from the
MCU as well who do you guys want to most
see what if it's like tangled like
Disney
like that and you're like what that
would be mean this is the one superhero
movie where that could happen you know
like it's and it would be to poke fun of
the Mojo spy spy spy or bad what we
spoiled my vitamin I feel like would be
one of harder ones cuz you sonido kind
of owns them it was like such a special
exception they had to score to get him
infinity war in Fantastic Four all of us
yeah yeah wouldn't make any yeah there's
a lot of confusing ideas here anything's
possible anything but probably it's Hugh
Jackman but it's not like Stanley I hope
it's not like it's going to be he'll
have his own cameo I hope they're like
oh the the cameo was because people were
speculating that Hugh Jackman would make
a cameo in the first and he did
technically on the People magazine cover
like now that he's now they can afford
him I can afford oh budget you know and
it was such a big hit the first time I'm
sure he'd show up you know I don't know
there's to it I know I think it might be
Hugh Jackman come on man you missed the
most fun cameo you had a great job you
did a great job with Logan one more time
yeah I think and as some are also saying
that uh it would be Channing Tatum
gambit would be upon one but just give
up on that because I never got the real
rogue you know that's why I mean you're
gonna get the real rogue could maybe
good maybe there's no rope in the real
gambit I know but there's room for just
Kim gambit yeah uh well let us know what
you most want to see is this will we'll
find out when the movie comes out and
more visit this conversation remember
like remember we thought it could be
Olaf wouldn't that have been fun
well now it's time to move on to our new
rock stars news lightning round
oh boy look at this new lightning round
card inside yeah we should have been
like animating SIF lightning things in
her seat okay well you guys were great
at tweeting us questions as always we
love you guys I'm gonna fire them at our
hosts we have to answer them as quickly
as without hesitation spots well are we
ready yeah yeah go
Maud yes Marvel was going to recast
Captain America or maybe like a legacy
thing what actor would you like to see
her in editon who isn't Aaron Edgerton
who's from Kingsman from Kingsman
[Music]
this lightning round Sam this
what would your Oasis avatar name be
name like name and I guess appearance so
question I love you player one yeah it's
got to not have my name in it right
because sometimes I just go with flash
bash you never want to use your name
yeah than I oh I will find you and blow
up your eyes yeah but I I was thinking
about this I think I'd want to go with
Sonic for a little bit I want to see
what that looks like okay but then I
don't want to stay with that for too
long when I like make an original
character but if I were to go in there
initially come on let's try Sonic out
let's see and I think it'd be kind of
fun if you could earn credits to like go
faster and faster and faster like
throughout like I guess you like the
races and stuff before flashback moto
with the zero and I'd be glad to real
because I has to be a Warner Brothers
franchise do you get a mention of Star
Wars over here but you can't see it or
maybe something Spielberg directed for
another studio but as long as Spielberg
directed and you only get the new
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles you don't
get the old ones I want to be Tom
Hanks's character in the terminal oh
there was an Easter Egg for that in the
movie it was really cool boilers for me
oh and I haven't said your names
I'm sorry uh at red jello gave the the
Oasis question at F seal 22 gave mods
question at Jo - Darwin wants to know
for me would you rather be trapped in
the world of Game of Thrones or The
Walking Dead who they're both pretty
awful to be trapped in right they both
have zombies now not The Walking Dead
cuz like both the human you have more
technology in the walking dead
yes Game of Thrones probably more fun
because you can have magic and Dragons
and um at least you can go to land where
there's yeah right yeah yeah sure
pirates you get a die kill or be
violated they say there's an opportunity
for indoor plumbing in the world of
Walking Dead some of those places have
like a satellite dishes and solar dishes
and stuff in
there's this is a lightning round turn
into sheet lightning in which what did
you pick oh I say Walking Dead thanks
guys and uh and for the future I came
out for a tweet in future weeks yeah
we're gonna start trying to do like a
Q&A show too so like keep those
questions coming we want to try to do
more interaction with with you guys and
get to know you better you guys can get
to know us better but next up let us
take a look at what we got in the
pipeline for videos coming out on this
channel in the next week
speaking of Walking Dead we'll have a
breakdown of episode 13 night um it's
also rumored that we will have an
Aquaman trailer you may there may
already be one but yeah I came out for a
breakdown whenever that comes out Sam's
doing is MC rewatch I am Avengers age of
Ultron coming out very soon I also did a
Jessica Jones breakdown for season 2 all
the Easter eggs I could find on there
there's some cool MCU phase 2 and phase
3 stuff they should go check out yeah
definitely and we have a we're gonna be
doing more stuff on infinity war it's
just gonna be like a regular thing you
can keep an eye on your channel it's not
for sure if we're gonna do this way but
I want to look into this whole theory on
whether or not cap has the soul stone
like people wondering how is he able to
resist the gauntlet I mean some people
are saying maybe has the soul stone
somewhere where is he hiding like put in
his Wheaties and yeah and then I will
see he's very blond in this maybe he's
yeah okay well I'm not doing the video I
don't have good theories for this okay
grisly all got beads in this one yeah oh
yeah oh yeah well guys now it comes to
our 15-second shout out where each of us
has 15 seconds to shout plug ramble
anything we want Samwell you start
alright you go over to the only stupid
answers youtube channel only stupid
Cersei did movie reviews for Tomb Raider
ready player one and Pacific Rim
uprising which is a garbage movie but it
is just so delightful to watch you want
to see toys just smack together for like
yeah now in 50 minutes yeah
good movie you're dumb you're dumb for
thinking that was supposed to be a good
film and I want a third well I'm gonna
compete with you for the ready play one
spoiler free review because you can get
mine over at geek bum was called for a
second breaking the fourth wall yet so
ready play one I really really enjoyed
it and I've read the book like three
times and I've done all I've been around
with this book nerd alert right yeah
we're on a show where we do know the
name of the game my time up but I'm just
gonna Infinity Gauntlet over you know
I'll shout out to my shirt because it's
kevin bacon and eggs oh that's a great
shirt for my 15 seconds I'm gonna shout
out our our comments section guys we
well we want to thank all of you who
have like been supportive and nice and
friendly in the comments for the rest of
you cut it out we're human beings we
read the comments we love interacting
with you but yeah we feel things we're
not just like a billboards that you can
scream all your horrible thoughts at so
yeah we're gonna start being more active
and engaging with you in the comments
and if you're using as a soapbox to like
air you're really awful views we're just
gonna we're gonna remove you and we yeah
don't be a bad person and and for those
of you who see it yeah this can be like
a group process you know let's let's try
to keep the tone civil and so many of
you so many of you have been great about
that and again we want to thank you we
don't wanna like censor anybody but just
like for our own like safety and our own
well-being yeah we're gonna have to
start doing that now
so yeah let's let's use those comment
sections to like show every other
youtube comment section what this should
be right yeah and yeah feel free to like
redirect the conversation away from like
us as people and towards like the crap
we're talking about we just we raised a
crazy idea that I broke down this
trailer for you but you're gonna comment
on me don't do that talk about the
trailer yeah don't share your weird
opinions down there there's all kinds of
you can share your weird opinions if
they're about like that oh yeah I want
to hear what do you think about like you
know
it's gonna get that salt down I don't
know we're nerds hey what you think he's
gonna do with the soul stone yeah yeah
hmm yes let's coffee all over myself be
adults here and like good people
okay well let's return to that trivia
question I can't wait oh boy Oh Billy so
yeah we're gonna redo our questions here
and then the question was in the first
step will movie what celebrity cameo was
cut from the movie it was a movie's
original closing scene for being too
insensitive thank you your sounds the
spaz Wow
I just went for it I wouldn't go for
broke Erik said Alex Trebek would she a
game show her yeah yeah the Jeopardy
host he like I know they had a joke
about Alex Trebek that they cut because
they're like I don't know if Alex Trebek
can take a joke I don't know if that's
the same Sam said guy theory show that
she made us a butterfly oh no problemo
doesn't have time for action lines mine
said Charlie Sheen and I feel like
that's the most correct that would I
feel like that's the most career I feel
like they try that's the time maybe he
didn't go for it or like this uh maybe
he's Charlie Sheen couple years ago did
something else that was maybe dumb well
and you know Charlie Sheen I know for
sure was on that chalkboard of the
Deadpool that they showed in the bar you
know and they had yeah I mean though the
answer is Amy Winehouse that's right
oh that isn't that isn't tasteful that's
not it so yeah they probably they wrote
a draft of the script and then she
passed away between that drafting passed
away a while yeah well if they wrote the
original draft of script in like 2007
and they shot it anyway no and they
didn't shoot it I think they've deleted
from the script and that was the
original idea I do remember something
about that vaguely in the commentary
that they had something they probably
showed her death they're like there's
gonna be some kind of crazy freak way
that she dies yeah that makes sense yeah
yeah that was those a tasteful tasteful
edit at least have some ones
that can defend themselves all right
well Devin we had Alex Trebek we had Guy
Fieri and we had high winds oh yeah
speed go Tiger blood I drink it every
morning no well I'm gonna have to do the
another news headline have to make jokes
mod can can do or goodbye Sam
unless why do you want to read the
headline and then ah okay great gives me
some time to think that although okay
well here we go in other news this week
mod take it away in other news Disney
has announced and you got a bubble in my
throat Disney has announced a new Marvel
themed sections of its park with Disney
California Adventure getting a guardians
of the galaxy section Disney Paris is
getting an adventure section and Disney
Hong Kong is getting an ant-man section
but you can't see it
meanwhile Disney Orlando in staying true
to its Floridian climate will get a go
on a Human Torch theme park joke there
why is that man getting a whole section
let's love them in the getting the
brownout stranger stranger things active
Winona Ryder and David Harbor received a
major pay rise for season three they're
gonna be getting four hundred and fifty
thousand dollars per episode wow that's
a real upside down flip from season 1 oh
[Music]
yeah I feel better about that
we're getting climbing up the hill we're
getting there mhm
Game of Thrones acted in professional
dire Sean Bean said that his natural
Yorkshire accent became the established
accent for northerners of Westeros on
the show
meanwhile the sound of him losing his
head became the established sound effect
for every death on the show zing
I like our dog a lot at ticket sales
that's okay I was gonna professional
ìlook ticket sales for Black Panther
have dropped in China where observers
believe that the film might be too
politically correct for a Chinese
audience mm well they're too busy watch
an ant-man I guess to uh to care about
watching the black panther I don't want
to make a derogatory comment about
Chinese people but uh but I guess
there's a there might be an observation
just like John bean you're killing this
joke Oh interesting
I guess do Chinese people have access to
YouTube I don't think they do don't they
have their own YouTube so I don't care
if we say hey stop being racist China
well they say they don't want to watch
Black Panther movies too politically
correct they don't want to watch it I
mean they'll watch movies as Will Smith
in it so I guess it's not a race thing
no interesting the west-world cast
promised that season two will make
season 1 look like a genteel kitchen
drama huh I guess if your kitchen
features you mean killing a bunch of
robots how is season 1 kitchen anything
that's a yeah no I made my joke
oh boy I'm sorry everybody
oh that's sad yeah man I miss tank I
can't believe I'm ashamed just done the
jokes this tank tank shirts thanks
tanked I'm trying to be funny when he
loses like a comment section here oh boy
well my do you want to take away our
goodbyes save us I mean I've destroyed
you guys already so I'm just gonna say
your name I want to thank our hosts Eric
Voss ei Voss is where you can find him
on Twitter we got Sam basher flash
basher hello no just no you're not a
flash battery or flash never know is
that Sam Bass huh and I'm Lord Garrett
at Maude Garrett on all the good things
and then throw a little bit of love at
only stupid answers also and a cute bomb
too cuz why not you can't have too much
geek your frites yeah definitely check
those channels out guys give them some
subs give them some love
comment down below tweet us here at new
rock stars like this video share it
around
subscribe to New York size follow dives
and stuff you love and we'll see you
next devon where's that lightning man